All right, welcome to another Zoom call.
We got some questions that came in.
Make sure you chat in any other questions that you have.
And let's get started.
So just so you know, I didn't update the slide,
but we actually have a trouble with YouTube.
They actually banned our channel.
We got it up and running again.
So you can see some YouTube videos.
We had to put just about every video on private.
I tell you, you don't think the conspiracy is real.
That you're not paying attention.
So it's pretty crazy.
So that means that I have a link that on the member site
on how to get to the members videos will be pushed to the,
at least for now, you'll be pushed to our new video site,
which is videos dot colors clinic.com or something like that.
And I have a link on the home page of the member site.
And I have a link on the Zoom call page of the member site,
just so you know, may have some availability on YouTube.
But it's just, it's a hit or miss thing right now.
So again, if you just join us, they literally shot our channel
down, took it off completely off everything for a while.
But hopefully we're back on right now.
OK, so to our questions, let's get going, think of positive things.
Do you think Extensitant is a good supplement to take?
And if so, are there any questions for a person with cancer
or for a person without cancer?
Yeah, well, the only caution with any supplement is purity-wise.
And a lot of supplements that you get,
that you can get over the color or some supplement on a house
or something like that might not be quality.
So it's purity is the most important thing
when we're talking about supplements, quality supplements.
We've hereby had a good quality Extensitant company.
I don't see any harm in taking that for cancer.
Again, you don't necessarily want to be taking too many things,
but there's nothing wrong with adding that to your protocol.
I watched the truth about cancer program
where a doctor was treating cancer patients
with raw pig or a creus.
Yep.
The doctor said it actually takes the protective coating off
the cancer cell so that your immune system can kill it.
I don't know if you ever heard of such a thing,
but if so, you think there's a benefit
to taking pancreatic enzymes of some sort.
I don't remember who's asking this question,
but I have written about this in my book.
I also have multiple blog posts about it,
multiple video posts about this.
This is enzyme therapy.
So enzyme therapy was developed by Dr. William Kelly
back in the 1950s.
And the only enzyme really that was available at that time
was pork pancreas enzyme.
So that's what he used as pork pancreas enzyme.
Dr. Nicholas Gonzalez was a promoter, Jay, of his.
Dr. Nicholas Gonzalez was a medical doctor
that broke off the establishment and practiced in upstate New York.
For many, many years, he used Dr. William Kelly's work
that affects he wrote a book on Dr. William Kelly.
And this is one another book that he wrote about concrete cancer
using pancreatic enzymes.
And he always used the pancreas pork enzymes.
Now, we have those enzymes on our store.
They are through the company allergy research.
That is the exact product that Dr. Nicholas used.
And we use enzyme therapy for a lot of people.
However, I do think that enzymes have improved over the decades.
And I wouldn't stick to something just because it was the only thing
available at the time.
Now, the negative about using the pancreas pork enzyme alone
is that typically that therapy is taking a lot of them
that we're talking about upwards to 150 capsules a day
under empty stomach.
So enzyme therapy in short is taking enzymes on an empty stomach
so that you're not using them to digest food,
but you're hopefully absorbing them
because you're taking high quantities of them
and you'll have an excess amount of enzyme circulating
in your bloodstream.
And they can break down, slash gobble up
the waste layer around the cancer
so that your immune system can attack it.
So it's very beneficial.
We have a number of people doing enzyme therapy.
Now, using the newer enzymes,
you can typically use far lower dose.
We've had people with different cancers use enzyme therapy
with great success, so but I test for that on everybody.
So if I didn't recommend enzyme therapy for you,
it's because it didn't test,
but it doesn't mean things you may feel led to do that.
So I have numerous blog posts on enzyme therapy.
I have much rich in about it in my stop by the cancer book as well.
And there's some videos on this stop by the cancer course
and some videos on the website probably on enzyme therapy.
So I know it sounds gross, but it's not gross.
It's just enzymes, it's pancreatic tissue,
enzymes and so there's nothing gross about it.
So it can be very beneficial.
I was thinking of adding B propolis to my supplements
as I've learned that it has anti-cancer properties.
I found it from a family-owned farm in Mississippi
and it's and it suggests you take 500 milligrams
one to three times a day.
Your thoughts please, thank you.
So B propolis can have a good immune stimulating property.
There's, you know,
I actually take some B pollen not every day,
but you at least a couple of times a week
to help with allergies and it can be an immune regulator.
So it helps balance the immune system.
It can be really good for autoimmune issues
because of its immune regulation property.
So it can, that could be, it could have good properties.
There's a lot of things,
anything that's going to be an immune regulator
or an immune stimulator is going to have cancer-killing properties.
There really isn't much downside to taking it.
It's very natural.
It's water-soluble.
It will flush out of your system.
It's not going to overload your liver.
So there's nothing wrong with taking B propolis.
You can't get it in a liquid form to spray
as a spray as well.
There's lots of different forms that you can give it.
Can the right machine use to help with testicular pain
or any pain for that matter?
Always with anything,
you always want to ask the question, why, right?
So if I have testicular pain or if I have kidney pain
or if I have pain in my big toe,
you always got to go, why?
And you want to treat the why.
So if I don't have, let's say,
if I don't have, if I know I have cancer,
testicular cancer, that's why I have pain, okay?
Then that's the reason why I just need to decrease the inflammation.
Can I use the right programs or pain?
Sure.
Can I use the right programs for inflammation?
So whatever you have pain,
some of the inflammation programs may be more appropriate to use.
So because lots of times pain is going to be caused
for inflammation,
now you also are asking the question, why,
why do I have inflammation too?
So you always want to treat the reason why.
So if I have pain in an area you want to try to figure that out,
if it can't be explained through something that you know
you have going on, you may want to dig into,
to see what is actually happening.
Remember, whenever I'm pain in any area in your body,
it can be referred pain.
So let's talk about testicular pain.
It's intermeded by my, I don't know,
I think maybe the Prudendal nerve.
It's coming out of your lower liver or sacral area.
Could the pain be referred because I have prostate cancer
or because I have,
so if I have pain due to something going on in my gut,
that A-fair fibers are going to fire back into my spinal cord
where it crosses my spinal cord and synapses
to an ascending A-fair fiber
and it's going to go up to my pride alone.
Neurology there, it can fire back
and you can get referred pain.
That's what referred pain is somewhere else in the body.
So you can get a referred pain that has nothing to do
with the area where you're having pain.
So investigating why you have pain is important
because it might not have anything to do with your testicle
or your big toe or your gut.
It could be how you could be getting referred pain
from something else.
So you want to investigate that.
That's why you do labs and scans and x-rays
and things like that to make sure you don't have something to wait on.
And if, let's say you have really bad testicular pain
and your cancer that you're dealing with is like,
I don't say liver cancer, it doesn't mean
you can't have more than one thing going on at the same time.
So it'd be good to get that examined.
We have a number of patients that might even be on this call
that have two or more different cancers.
So now we have metastasized cancer.
Let's say if you have breast cancer and metastasized
to your lung, it's still breast cancer.
We should go to have two different cancers.
And we have several patients that have two different cancers.
Lung cancer and breast cancer, totally different cancers
unrelated to one of them.
So, but also you can have other things going on.
Other things that can cause testicular pain,
pain is blockage that can cause inflammation.
So, you want to get those things checked out
to make sure you're done.
Just using the right machine to cover up something also.
You don't want to use any nutrition
or any natural things to cover up
like your body's trying to tell you.
So you want to investigate to the cause.
I have a double mastectomy scheduled for April 5th.
I've read your post regarding tumor removal and fasting
to tell regulate MTOR and IGF post surgery.
Should fasting start the day after surgery?
I would start the day of surgery.
So that's when I will start the day of surgery.
And to, you know, at least a 24 hour fast,
maybe even a 48 hour fast,
but that's how you can tolerate it that can help you heal the best.
So, and then consider intermittent fasting
or time restricted eating after that
so that you're getting a fasting like environment in your body
so that you're not getting a regulation of them.
Should with which supplements should I continue
to take pre-imposed surgery?
Would you recommend Cheekswabs pre-imposed surgery?
No, necessarily maybe a conversation with me would be good
because then I could take a deeper dive
into your supplements that are going to last this question
and then I can give you an analysis
about that probably the best thing.
Would you recommend CBC or other lab tests
pre-imposed surgery?
I would certainly think that they would do that.
I would certainly think that they would do that
at the hospital post-surgery.
You know, they would be hugely amiss
without making sure that your electrolytes aren't balanced
before letting you be dismissed from the hospital.
So yes, getting a CBC with complete metabolic panel
pre-imposed surgery would be appropriate.
The oncologist has suggested starting to do oral chemo
with an estrogen blocker of about two weeks post-surgery.
So if you do make it a point
as we could discuss that as well.
Last week I posed a question regarding nicotine patches,
IV applications, IV cancer.
You were familiar but said you can do it
happy on the opportunity to do so.
I haven't had an opportunity to do a deep dive.
Of course, you can't find anything on the internet
on Google about this except negative things about nicotine.
I haven't got a chance to dive into alternative approaches
to that.
I would think that it's working on an oxidative stress issue
because at least my understanding
of everything that's out there research-wise nicotine
is it causes oxidative stress.
So you're just a side note about that.
You know, that gets into should a cancer patient take antioxidant.
I think I talked about it the last week.
Zoom call when somebody asked a question about should all
breast cancer patients be a glutathione?
And I said no, absolutely not.
glutathione is one of your strongest
intercellular antioxidants.
And you know, what chemo does is works as an oxidizing agent
to kill cancer cells because cancer cells,
because they're rapidly replicated,
they're not producing adequate amounts of glutathiles.
So they're more susceptible to reactive oxygen species,
oxidative stress, any oxidative agents.
And that's why chemo can kill that directly.
So when you're just taking a whole bunch of antioxidants,
you could be supporting the life of cancer cell.
So it's all about balance with oxidative stress,
slash antioxidant to block oxidative stress.
While oxidative stress can cause cancer,
antioxidant can prevent that oxidative stress
cause of cancer.
Once a person has cancer and oxidative therapy,
maybe once in the best interest.
I mean, that's how leotrilo works, B17.
That's how protocell works.
That's how some other therapies works
as they stimulate oxidative stress
or stimulate production of reactive oxygen species.
They're like killing the cancer.
So no, not that everybody shouldn't be on high dose
or they're the antioxidants.
So I think that is the mechanism of action with the nicotine
as you see as an oxidative stress agent.
So it could be wrong.
But I think that's what makes the most sense
for my vet amount of extremities.
In the last three weeks, my ankles are swollen.
They are better and demortied.
Is it because of the kidneys?
I heard too much sodium, potassium,
and phosphorus could do that.
Yeah, so getting a CBC in a complete metabolic panel,
you could look at that and see if your electrolytes
are on a balance.
So any kind of imbalance in electrolytes
can affect the retention of fluid.
So your kidneys have stimulation by the forebode
produced in your pancreas that stimulates the uptake
of fluid and the release of fluid.
So if you have too much fluid that is being retained
that's not being excreted by your kidneys,
then you could have an increased fluid
in your extremities or elsewhere.
Can be other reasons for that too.
Something as simple as posture while you're sleeping,
whether they're better in the morning,
would be something physical as posture while you're sitting.
So people that are sitting at a desk all day
or people that aren't moving,
people that are standing on their feet all day.
It's really not a kidney function
that they're getting fluid in their lower extremities.
It's a heart issue.
So as far as moving fluid out of the tissues
and into the limb system,
it's a function of muscular contraction.
But as far as pumping blood back from your lower extremities,
that's a function of your heart.
So somebody with congestive heart failure,
weakening of the heart,
weakening of the strength of the heart contraction
is gonna have an excess fluid in their extremities,
especially lower extremities.
So making sure you're moving,
you're sitting in a desk all day,
you're moving your toes, moving your feet,
writing an alphabet that's your feet,
all these different lymphatic things
that we have written on some blogs.
So it's not always a chemical issue.
It can be postural, can be hard,
can there's a lot of different possibilities.
That's what are your thoughts on the low carb keto diet
to reduce carbs and sugars since cancer is a bit about
disease and its energy is driven by sugars and carbs.
I'm on an under 50 gram carb diet.
Oh, it eat plenty of protein, organic, free range
and plant-based things.
Yes, we write about that a lot.
You know, most cancers are going to find a fuel source.
The easiest fuel source is glucose.
So, and then they find the glucose,
they feed very, cancer cells to the feed very inefficiently.
Through the endpoint of glucose,
it's not through the Krebs cycle.
So they feed through lactate,
which is an anaerobic function
of fuel source, which is inefficient,
but it partly has to do with issues with the HIF.
The HIF1 gene partly has to do with the cancer cells
rapid replication isn't producing a lot of the enzyme
to convert peruvian acid into acetylquins.
They may necessary to go into the Krebs cycle
so it converts it to lactic acid,
and it eats off the lactic acid.
So, yes, going out a low carb diet,
a keto-like diet, and measuring your glucose,
don't have to necessarily get into full ketosis,
but measure your glucose levels
and try to get your glucose down into the 70s.
Information has come out about how you have just
as good a success with a cancer patient,
but that's a try to get into full ketosis.
It's very difficult to be in full ketosis,
and to stay in full ketosis.
It's not altogether necessary,
so if you can be on a keto-like diet,
where you're getting your glucose levels down
as low as possible,
you could have just as good a success.
So, measuring your carbs per gram can be really good,
but everybody's a little bit different.
So, I mean, you could be eating only 40 grams of carbs a day
and your glucose is still at 98,
fasting, blood glucose, still at 98,
and this is where going on a type of circadian eater,
some sort of modified, faster diet to help reset
that metabolism can be beneficial.
So, measuring your blood glucose,
I think gives you a more accurate picture
of where your gram per day carbs should be at.
So, you also don't wanna go into a hypoglycemic state
where your blood glucose is down below 50 or something
like that, and you're getting the shakes and all that
to the stuff.
So, measuring your blood glucose,
I think is a good way to go.
Any other questions?
All right, well, we will sign off for tonight.
Thank you all for being on,
and make your questions in.
It will start off again next week.
All right, bye-bye.